This episode is sponsored by Newport Healthcare, providing results-driven treatment for teens and young adults ages 12 to 28 who are struggling with trauma, depression, anxiety, and co-occurring issues like eating disorders and substance abuse. Newport's trauma-informed programs incorporate experiential activities like adventure therapy, mixed martial arts, dance, and zip lining because we know that moving the body benefits the mind and aids in healing mental health conditions. Learn more at Newport Healthcare.com. April is Stress Awareness Month, which this year seems more relevant than ever. The American Psychological Association's most recent stress in America survey
本期节目的赞助商是 Newport Healthcare，他们为12至28岁、正与创伤、抑郁、焦虑以及饮食失调和药物滥用等并发问题作斗争的青少年和年轻人提供注重结果的治疗。Newport 的创伤知情项目结合了体验式活动，如冒险疗法、综合格斗、舞蹈和溜索，因为我们知道，身体活动有益于心理，并有助于治愈心理健康状况。请访问 Newport Healthcare.com 了解更多信息。四月份是压力意识月，今年这个主题似乎比以往任何时候都更加贴切。美国心理学协会最近的“美国压力”调查
fielded in February and March found record high levels of stress among Americans of all ages. That stress was tied to inflation and economic uncertainty, global tensions amid Russia's invasion of Ukraine, all compounded by two years of the COVID-19 pandemic. More than 87% of respondents to the poll said that rising prices were a source of significant stress for them, while 81% cited global uncertainty as a significant stressor. In recent decades, research has found that stress can harm our physical
于2月和3月进行，发现所有年龄段的美国人的压力水平都达到了创纪录的高位。这种压力与通货膨胀和经济不确定性、俄罗斯入侵乌克兰带来的全球紧张局势有关，再加上两年新冠肺炎疫情的交织影响。民意调查显示，超过87%的受访者表示，物价上涨给他们带来了巨大的压力，而81%的人则将全球不确定性列为巨大的压力源。近几十年来，研究发现，压力会损害我们的身体
as well as our mental health, through its complex effects on our brain, body, and immune system. So how does stress get under our skin to affect our health? health? What are the biological pathways through which this happens? Do different types of stress affect us differently? Is it possible to measure stress objectively and to figure out whether the level of stress we're under is high enough to harm our health? And when we do feel stress, what are some strategies we can use to manage it and minimize its negative effects? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association,
以及心理健康，这是因为它对我们的大脑、身体和免疫系统产生了复杂的影响。那么，压力是如何进入我们的皮肤并影响我们的健康的呢？发生这种情况的生物学途径是什么？不同类型的压力对我们的影响是否不同？是否有可能客观地测量压力，并弄清楚我们所承受的压力水平是否高到足以损害我们的健康？当我们感到压力时，我们可以采取哪些策略来管理它并将其负面影响降到最低？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. George Slavich, professor and director of the Laboratory for Stress Assessment and Research at the University of California, Los Angeles, where he studies the psychological and biological mechanisms that links stress with poor health. Dr. Slavich is an expert on the basic science, assessment,
它探讨了心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是乔治·斯拉维奇博士（Dr. George Slavich），他是加利福尼亚大学洛杉矶分校压力评估与研究实验室的教授兼主任，在那里他研究将压力与健康状况不佳联系起来的心理和生物学机制。斯拉维奇博士是基础科学、评估领域的专家，
and management of life stress. He developed the first online system for assessment lifetime stress exposure and is a pioneer in a new field of research called human social genomics that looks at how social stress affects the human genome. His work on the psycho-neuroimmunology of stress and health has been published in many leading scientific journals and covered by media outlets, including the New York Times, the Washington Post and Scientific American, among others. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Shlavich. Kim, thank you so much and thank you so much for giving some air time to this topic that is on all of our minds, stress what we can do about it
以及生活压力的管理。他开发了第一个用于评估终生压力暴露的在线系统，并且是人类社会基因组学这一新兴研究领域的先驱，该领域研究社会压力如何影响人类基因组。他在压力的心理神经免疫学和健康方面的工作已发表在许多领先的科学期刊上，并被《纽约时报》、《华盛顿邮报》和《科学美国人》等媒体报道。非常感谢您今天能加入我，斯拉维奇博士。金，非常感谢你，也非常感谢你给这个我们所有人都在关心的话题留出一些播出时间，压力、我们能做些什么
and how we can all build back stronger. Yes, we will be talking about that. And as I mentioned a minute ago, you're an expert in psycho-neuroimmunology, which is a pretty big mouthful. So can you break that down into its parts and explain what it is and how stress affects our physical health? Yes. Psycho-neuroimmunology is a very fancy time. for a very simple concept. We all know that when we're stressed, we have different thoughts that pop into our mind, like this is never going to end, am I doing well, I'm failing, you know, everybody's left me, I may never get over this. And those thoughts that pop into our mind are obviously getting represented by our brain in some way. And then our brain is really the
以及我们如何才能以更强的姿态重建。是的，我们将会讨论这个。正如我刚才提到的，你是心理神经免疫学领域的专家，这是一个相当拗口的词。那么你能把它拆开并解释一下它是什么以及压力如何影响我们的身体健康吗？好的。心理神经免疫学是一个非常花哨的词，用来表达一个非常简单的概念。我们都知道，当我们感到压力时，我们的脑海中会浮现出各种不同的想法，比如这永远不会结束，我做得好吗，我失败了，你知道的，大家都离开我了，我可能永远也走不出这个阴影了。而这些浮现在我们脑海中的想法显然正在以某种方式被我们的大脑所表征。然后我们的大脑真的是
captain that is guiding the rest of our body. I mean, our brain can tell our immune system to ramp up or ramp down and lead to a lot of other biological changes that ultimately affect not just our mental health, but our physical health as well. And so if you just think about the term psycho-neuroimmunology, it's essentially just gluing together the three things that I mentioned. Our psychology, and how we experience the world. Neuroscience, which is the neurobiology of how we appraise and think of those things that are happening to us in the world. And then our immunology, which is, as we know now, relevant for a lot of different
指导我们身体其余部分的船长。我的意思是，我们的大脑可以告诉我们的免疫系统加强或减弱，并导致许多其他生物学变化，这些变化最终不仅影响我们的心理健康，也影响我们的身体健康。因此，如果你细想“心理神经免疫学”这个词，它本质上只是把提到的三件事粘合在一起。我们的心理，以及我们如何体验世界。神经科学，也就是我们如何评估和思考世界上发生的事情的神经生物学。然后是我们的免疫学，正如我们现在所知，它与许多不同的事物相关
mental and physical health problems. So maybe an easier way to think of it is mind-body medicine, where we think about how the brain is regulating the body and how the body, in turn, influences the brain. But as I said, it's just a complicated term for a very simple idea, which is how our psychology influences our neurobiology, our immune system, and vice versa. So some of the stressors I talked about in the introduction, like war and inflation, are big global stressors. Did those kinds of stressors affect us differently from more personal social stressors, like, say, a divorce or a breakup?
心理和身体健康问题。所以也许一种更容易的思考方式是身心医学，我们思考大脑如何调节身体，以及身体反过来如何影响大脑。但正如我所说，这只是一个复杂术语，对应一个非常简单的想法，即我们的心理如何影响我们的神经生物学、免疫系统，反之亦然。因此，我在引言中谈到的一些压力源，如战争和通货膨胀，是巨大的全球性压力源。这些类型的压力源对我们的影响是否不同于更个人的社会压力源，比如说离婚或分手？
I think we all, first of all, in some way, we're all experts on stress now if we weren't two years ago. And in some way, I feel like there's a lot of atmospheric pressure. We all have in some ways felt like we've been in this stress pressure cooker with uncertainty in the world, with changes in the economic situation. But the other things you mentioned are really individual level stressors. And it's interesting to me that the survey maybe didn't bring some of those individual level stressors to the top of people's minds quite as much as I think they actually are in our lived experience. So in my job and maybe in your job as well and a lot of our listeners, our entire personal lives, or certainly our professional lives have been recalibrated, thrown up in the air. juggled about in terms of needing to work from home, figuring out health care, child care
首先，我想我们所有人，如果两年前还不是的话，现在某种程度上都是压力方面的专家了。在某种程度上，我觉得有很多大气压力。我们所有人都以某种方式觉得，自己一直处在这个充满不确定性的世界和不断变化的经济形势的压力高压锅里。但你提到的其他事情实际上是个人层面的压力源。令我感兴趣的是，这项调查可能并没有像我认为它们实际上存在于我们的生活经验中那样，把其中一些个人层面的压力源推到人们最关心的位置。因此，在我的工作中，也许在你的工作以及我们的许多听众的工作中，我们的整个个人生活，或者至少是我们的职业生活，已经被重新校准，抛向空中。
responsibilities, whether or not to retire or not to retire. These are all, this is a lot of cognitive upheaval and reshuffling of our social relationships. I mean, we're all used to going into work and meeting with colleagues and going to lunch with colleagues and essentially using the social support and the social network around us. So in addition to these global things like the financial markets in Ukraine, I think we also need to think about and speak about how our own personal lives have been thrown up in the air and for many of us are still in flux. And that in and of itself has degraded the grounding and the predictability. I think that we all would normally rely on to get through these big macro stressors like uncertainty in the financial
在需要在家工作、弄清楚医疗保健、儿童保育等问题上进行了颠簸。责任，无论是退休还是不退休。这些都是大量的认知剧变和我们社会关系的重新洗牌。我的意思是，我们都习惯于去上班，与同事开会，与同事共进午餐，并基本上利用我们周围的社会支持和社会网络。因此，除了金融市场和乌克兰等全球性事件之外，我们还需要思考和谈论我们自己的个人生活是如何被抛向空中并且对我们许多人来说仍然处于不确定状态的。这本身就削弱了根基和可预测性。我认为我们所有人通常都会依靠这些来度过这些大的宏观压力源，比如金融市场的不确定性
markets or uncertainty with war and peace. So just to answer your question, we know from a lot of research that we've done that social relationships are incredibly important for getting us through difficult times. And there's a whole neurobiological reason for that that we may get into. But in the absence of these close social bonds and predictable social networks, the more macro-stressers that we face all can have a much greater toll than they otherwise would. So what does stress do to our bodies that is so unhealthy and even dangerous in many cases? Well, the first thing we need to do is to give some kind of definition to that perniquity term stress because everybody uses it in a very different way. And so it's useful to kind of say what is it that we actually mean when we use the word stress?
市场或战争与和平的不确定性。所以回答你的问题，我们从我们做过的大量研究中得知，社会关系对于让我们度过艰难时期极其重要。这里面有全部的神经生物学原因，我们可能会深入探讨。但在缺乏这些亲密的社会纽带和可预测的社会网络的情况下，我们所面临的更多宏观压力源所带来的代价可能会比平时更大。那么，压力对我们的身体做了什么，以至于在许多情况下如此不健康甚至危险？好吧，我们首先要做的是给这个臭名昭著的术语“压力”下一个定义，因为每个人使用它的方式都非常不同。因此，说明当我们使用“压力”这个词时，我们实际指的是什么，是很有用的。
And I prefer to just make a quick distinction between stressors, which are things that actually happen to us like losing a job or getting divorced or. or learning of some bad financial information or having to move houses versus stress, which is sort of an abstract, not abstract, but a general term for all of the consequences of experiencing those stressors. So the stressor might be getting divorced. The term stress may refer to the psychological and physiological and immunologic changes that are really the sequelae from that experience.
我更倾向于对压力源（stressors）和压力（stress）做一个快速的区分，压力源是实际发生在我们身上的事情，比如失业、离婚或。或者了解到一些不好的财务信息，或者不得不搬家，而压力则是对经历这些压力源的所有后果的一个抽象的（也不是抽象的，但总的）统称。因此，压力源可能是离婚。而“压力”一词则可能指心理、生理和免疫学上的变化，这些变化确实是该经历带来的后遗症。
And to sort of understand why stressors would impact the brain and the body, we have to think about what's really the primary purpose or the primary function of the human brain in the immune system. And in my writing, I make the argument that the primary purpose of the brain in the immune system is to keep the body biologically safe. And, you know, one way that the brain does that is by guiding us toward friendly other people, socially supportive relationships, people who can keep us physically and socially safe. And at the same time, try to keep us generally away from situations that might pose physical harm to us.
为了理解为什么压力源会影响大脑和身体，我们必须思考人类大脑和免疫系统真正的主要目的或主要功能是什么。在我的文章中，我提出这样一个观点：大脑和免疫系统的主导目的是保持身体在生物学上的安全。而且，你知道，大脑实现这一目标的一种方式是引导我们走向友善的其他人、社会支持的关系、能够保证我们身体和社交安全的人。与此同时，尽量让我们普遍远离可能对我们造成身体伤害的情况。
And the immune system is actually in cahoots with this goal of keeping us biologically safe. The immune system can turn on in the presence of different pathogens. So, for example, when you get a cut on your arm, you may see some redness and swelling, some heat in that location. And that's essentially a localized inflammatory response that is intended to keep a the body biologically safe and to limit the spread of infection. Now, in order to, in order to serve that purpose well, we think one thing that happened was that the immune system gained the ability to talk with the human brain, to talk with the brain, and to increase inflammation, not just after some kind of physical damage had already occurred to the body,
免疫系统实际上与保持我们生物学安全的这个目标同流合污。在存在不同病原体的情况下，免疫系统可以被激活。例如，当你的手臂被割伤时，你可能会看到一些红肿和该部位发热。这本质上是一种局部的炎症反应，旨在保持身体在生物学上的安全并限制感染的扩散。现在，为了很好地实现这一目的，我们认为发生的一件事是，免疫系统获得了与人类大脑对话、与大脑对话并增加炎症的能力，而不仅仅是在身体已经发生某种物理损伤之后，
but in anticipation or in advance of that physical wounding occurring. So I'll just give you an example. If you are, let's say, now several thousand years ago and you're amongst a group of individuals who you didn't know well, and all of a sudden that interaction turned from very, very friendly to hostile, what your brain would, we hypothesize, would do is to call up, pick up the red phone, call up the immune system and say, hey, immune system, I hope you're doing well today. I just noticed that, you know, I thought this conversation was going really well, but it
而是在该物理伤口发生之前或预先。所以我举个例子。如果你是，比方说，现在几千年前，你身处一群你不太了解的个人之中，突然之间，这种互动从非常非常友善变成了敌对，我们假设你的大脑会做的是，拿起红电话，给免疫系统打电话，说，嘿，免疫系统，希望你今天过得好。我刚注意到，你知道，我以为这次对话进展得很顺利，但它
turns out that these other villagers don't look quite so nice. And I don't know what's going to happen, but this situation may go sour, and I'm seeing some angry faces out there, and I just want you to be prepared in case this interaction goes south and turns conflictual, and at some point we might get into a fight. So the reason that the brain would have that sort of red-phone connection with the immune system is that at the first indication of the presence of some kind of social conflict or social danger, the immune system could turn on, release these immune cells into all compartments of the body. And if physical wounding actually occurred, those immune cells would be ready and primed to
事实证明，这些村民看起来没那么好。我不知道会发生什么，但这种情况可能会变质，我看到外面有一些生气的面孔，我只是想让你做好准备，以防这次互动变质并引发冲突，在某个时候我们可能会打起来。因此，大脑与免疫系统建立这种红电话连接的原因是，在出现某种社会冲突或社会危险的第一迹象时，免疫系统可以被激活，将这些免疫细胞释放到身体的所有隔室中。如果真的发生了物理损伤，这些免疫细胞将准备就绪并做好准备
accelerate wound healing and recovery just in case that physical wound healing would have occurred. And just to put a bow on this little monologue here, my point is that we, that we, all would have been selected for having that early detection system, early threat detection system, whereby the brain would have told the immune system to ramp up in anticipation of potential physical wounding occurred. And those among us who didn't have that anticipatory response are likely no longer around us because, well, their immune system would, have had as an efficient of a response to actual physical wounding when it occurred as compared to those of us who mounted that anticipatory response.
加速伤口愈合和恢复，以防真的发生物理伤口愈合。为了给这段小独白做个总结，我的观点是，我们，我们所有人都被选择拥有那种早期检测系统、早期威胁检测系统，通过该系统，大脑会告诉免疫系统在预期可能发生物理伤口时进行加强。而我们当中那些没有这种预判反应的人可能已经不在我们身边了，因为，好吧，当实际物理伤口发生时，他们的免疫系统不会像我们这些做出这种预判反应的人那样做出有效的反应。
So living as we are right now with a lot of stress, does that mean that our bodies are on alert all the time? Is that what's happening to a lot of us? And therefore, you know, your immune system is in overdrive. It's doing things that you don't need it. to do, but your brain is telling it to do. Yeah, and I love that you ended that sentence on the brain because I think that's really the crux of the point. You know, for some of us, when we're in this stress pressure cooker and thinking about Ukraine and thinking about our financial situation and feeling lonely and upset about the state
因此，正如我们现在这样生活在充满压力的环境中，这是否意味着我们的身体一直处于戒备状态？我们很多人都是这样吗？因此，你知道，你的免疫系统超负荷运转。它在做你不需要它做的事情，但你的大脑却在告诉它去做。是的，我很高兴你以大脑结束了这句话，因为我认为这才是问题的关键。你知道，对于我们中的一些人来说，当我们身处这个充满压力的压力锅中，想着乌克兰，想着我们的财务状况，感到孤独，并对现状感到沮丧时
of the world, we may be stuck in that mental state of of ruminating about the negative things that have happened, feeling socially disconnected, feeling alone, feeling as though we're not sure what the future is going to bring, and whether or not we're, you know, whether or not we're essentially going to be able to continue as we all were pre-pandemic. Whereas for all, for others of us, we are not perseverating on those particular topics.
在这个世界上，我们可能会陷入这样一种精神状态：对已经发生消极事情进行反刍，感到社会脱节，感到孤独，觉得我们不确定未来会带来什么，以及我们是否，你知道，是否基本上能够像大流行之前那样继续下去。然而，对于所有人，对于我们中的其他人，我们并没有纠结于这些特定的话题。
We may think about a negative news item that pops up on our phone, but then once the negative news item goes away, we're no longer thinking about it anymore. And so the question really in terms of the negative health effects is not just whether we think about it when these negative situations arise, but how long and how often do we ruminate about them and perseverate about them when they're no longer in front of us? And I think Robert Sapolsky's, you know,
我们可能会想到手机上弹出的负面新闻，但一旦负面新闻消失，我们就不再考虑它了。因此，就对健康的负面影响而言，问题实际上不仅在于当这些消极情况出现时我们会不会想到它，而在于当它们不再在我们面前时，我们会反刍多久、多久会沉溺于其中？我认为罗伯特·萨波尔斯基的，你知道，
why zebras don't get ulcers book, which really captures this idea quite succinctly, which is that in most of the animal kingdom, animals are thinking about these threats in the environment, but only as long as they're present. And when the threats are gone, the thoughts then subside and animals go along their merry way. Whereas humans have this incredible capacity, both for better and for worse, to symbolically represent and to imagine negative situations, even when those situations are not directly in front of us. So I like to use the example of maybe you have a nasty boss and, you know, some calls.
《为什么斑马不得溃疡》（Why Zebras Don't Get Ulcers）这本书非常简洁地捕捉到了这个观点，即在大多数动物王国中，动物们都在思考环境中的这些威胁，但只有在它们存在时才这样想。当威胁消失后，想法就会消退，动物们就会高高兴兴地继续过它们的日子。然而，人类拥有这种令人难以置信的能力，无论好坏，能够象征性地表征和想象消极的情况，即使这些情况并不直接在我们眼前。所以我喜欢用这个例子：也许你有一个讨厌的老板，你知道，有些电话。
conflict between the two of you or you don't necessarily get along and you have a meeting with them on Friday at 3 p.m. Well, for some of us, you know, we wake up Monday morning and we start thinking about that meeting now Monday 9 a.m., Monday during lunch, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, you know, by Friday, our stomach is turned upside down and all we can think about is how that conversation is going to go. But not just that, you know, we're thinking that it's not going to go well, that he or she is going to criticize me, et cetera. So what we've essentially done is that our brain has symbolically represented that stressor now Monday morning, Monday afternoon, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, Thursday,
你们两个之间有冲突，或者你们不一定相处得很好，你周五下午3点有个会议。好吧，对于我们中的一些人来说，你知道，我们周一早上醒来，现在从周一早上9点、周一午餐期间、周二、周三、周四就开始考虑那个会议了，你知道的，到周五，我们的胃都翻江倒海了，我们满脑子想的都是那场对话会怎么进行。不仅如此，你知道，我们认为它不会顺利进行，他或她会批评我，等等。所以我们本质上做的是，我们的大脑在周一早上、周一下午、周二、周三、周四、周四象征性地表征了那个压力源，
Friday, even though that stupid meeting is only from 3 to 3.30. Right? We laugh, but we all know that we do this from time to time or we know other people who've done it. Whereas for others of us, you know, we've saved ourselves four and a half days of the stress response because we're honestly not even thinking of how that meeting is going to go until 255 on Friday afternoon, in which case that the presence of that stressor is actually only 35 minutes. And there's another overlay to that, which is that we may not even go into that situation
周五，尽管那个愚蠢的会议只从3点开到3点30分。对吧？我们笑了，但我们都知道我们有时会这样做，或者我们知道其他人也这样做。然而对于我们中的其他人来说，你知道，我们为自己省去了四个半老天的应激反应，因为老实说，我们甚至在周五下午2点55分之前都不会去想那场会议会怎么进行，在这种情况下，那个压力源的存在实际上只有35分钟。这里还有另一层含义，那就是我们甚至可能不会进入那种情况
thinking that the worst is going to occur, we may understand that our boss is not the easiest person, but we actually look at that situation as an opportunity to tell our boss about all the amazing work that we've done recently and to sort of celebrate our own work and the work of our team. So, you know, that's the funny way in which the human brain has gained the capacity to think about other people's thoughts and intentions and actually to take those thoughts and intentions
想到最坏的情况可能会发生，我们可能会觉得老板不是个容易相处的人，但我们实际上把这种情况看作是一个机会，向老板讲述我们最近完成的所有出色工作，并借此庆祝我们自己和团队的工作成果。所以，你知道，人类的大脑就是以这种有趣的方式获得了思考他人想法和意图的能力，甚至能够去把握这些想法和意图
and the likelihood of certain situations occurring, which is really useful for getting us to get along and cooperate. Because, of course, if we weren't able to imagine what was in the mind of our boss, we may not be able to anticipate it very well or to meet our coworkers where they are or, you know, meet the demands. So it has an upside in terms of being able to foster cooperation, but it also has a downside, which enables us to symbolically represent and imagine things that are negative,
以及某些情况发生的可能性，这对于我们相处和合作非常有用。因为，当然，如果我们无法想象老板心里在想什么，我们可能就无法很好地预测它，也无法迎合同事的需求或满足各种要求。因此，它在促进合作方面有积极的一面，但它也有消极的一面，那就是它让我们能够象征性地表达和想象消极的事物，
even when they're not actually happening. So what are some of the effective ways, then, that people can alleviate those kinds of stress or at least mitigate the harm that it might be doing to their health? Well, I love that nasty boss example because it brings mindfulness techniques to the forefront. So, you know, the simple way that I think about mindfulness meditation is that you have these, you know, negative thoughts that pop into our mind and, you know, we all have these negative thoughts. Am I good enough? I'm not doing well. I have a difficult meeting tomorrow.
即使这些事物并没有真正发生。那么，人们有哪些有效的方法可以减轻这些压力，或者至少减轻它可能对健康造成的损害呢？我很喜欢那个讨厌的老板的例子，因为它把正念技巧推到了最前沿。所以，你知道，我对正念冥想的简单理解是，你的脑海中会突然涌现出这些消极的想法，而且，你知道，我们所有人都有这些消极的想法。我够优秀吗？我做得不好。我明天有个艰难的会议。
I'm not prepared. It's not going to go well. And what you notice is that all of those thoughts, some of them are kind of about the present, but a lot of them are about negative possible things happening in the future. For others of us, maybe we tend to ruminate about negative things that have happened in the past. Why the hell did I say that? I can't believe. I can't believe. I said that, you know, his shirt didn't fit or that, you know,
我没有准备好。事情不会顺利的。你会发现，所有这些想法中，有些是关于现在的，但很多都是关于未来可能发生的消极事情。对我们其他人来说，也许我们倾向于反刍过去发生的消极事情。我特么刚才为什么那么说？我真不敢相信。我真不敢相信。我竟然说那件衬衫不合身，或者说，
that comment was stupid. What are people thinking about me now because I said that? I really wasn't prepared. I should have done better. You know, I should have been a better partner. Those are, you know, ruminative thoughts about negative things that might have happened in the past. So just in terms of the state of mind, our mind can often drift to negative thoughts that are focused on the future, negative thoughts that are focused on the past. What I like about mindful meditation is that the idea is to non-judgmentally identify that your thoughts are floating into the future, floating into the past, and gently bring your awareness back to the present where, guess what, things are actually pretty good.
那条评论太蠢了。因为我说了这话，别人现在会怎么看我？我真的没有准备好。我本该做得更好的。你知道，我本该成为一个更好的伴侣。这些都是关于过去可能发生的消极事情的反刍思维。所以，就精神状态而言，我们的大脑经常会飘向专注于未来的消极想法，以及专注于过去的消极想法。我喜欢正念冥想的地方在于，它的理念是不带评判地识别出你的思想正飘向未来、飘向过去，然后轻柔地将你的注意力带回现在，而你猜怎么着，现在的实际情况其实挺不错的。
You know, you're not sitting in front of your boss. You're sitting for a cup of coffee with somebody who you love. You're reading a delightful book that you really enjoy. You're laying on the sand listening to the waves go in and out. You're laying in the grass, feeling the grass and the fresh air and the sun beaming down on your face. Now, of course, now while you're doing that, you know, now the boss is creeping into your head again, right? So that mindfulness practice is gently and graciously bringing that awareness back to the present. So that actually what you're doing is you're limiting, you're reducing the amount of time that your mind is floating to the future and floating to the past, bringing it back to the present where actually everything is okay.
你知道，你不是坐在老板面前。你是在和自己爱的人坐在一起喝咖啡。你在读一本让你真正享受的开心的书。你躺在沙滩上听着海浪此起彼伏。你躺在草地上，感受着青草、新鲜空气和洒在脸上的阳光。当然，现在，当你做这些的时候，你知道，老板又开始悄悄溜进你的脑海了，对吧？所以这种正念练习就是轻柔而优雅地把注意力带回到现在。这样一来，你实际上是在限制、在减少你的大脑飘向未来和过去的时间，把它拉回现在，而实际上一切都安好。
And just if we turn that practice into the minutes of the day, what you can see is that the number of minutes that you practice, that mindfulness technique, the fewer minutes your brain is telling your immune system potentially to ramp up in preparation of some kind of threat, which as I've just kind of illustrated is that is actually not there because where you are, is on a lovely beach or your fluffy couch where those threats are not in front of you. So that's my favorite one go-to. And it's something that we can all practice for free with no tools. We don't have to purchase anything to do that. Right, right. And now we're going to take a short break. This episode is sponsored by Newport Healthcare, the answer to today's mental health crisis
如果我们把这种练习融入到一天的点滴中，你会发现，你练习这种正念技巧的分钟数越多，你的大脑向免疫系统发出潜在警报、为某种威胁做准备的分钟数就越少。正如我刚才所阐述的，这种威胁其实并不存在，因为你所在的地方是一个美丽的沙滩或者你舒适的沙发上，那些威胁并不在你面前。所以这是我最喜欢的首选方法。而且这是我们可以免费练习的东西，不需要任何工具。我们不需要购买任何东西来做到这一点。对，对。现在我们要稍作休息。本期节目由 Newport Healthcare 赞助，它是当今心理健康危机答案
and offering sustainable healing for teens and young adults struggling with mental health issues and co-occurring disorders. Newport Healthcare is dedicated to providing accessible and ethical care to young people struggling with mental health concerns. Newport offers a full continuum of care at locations across the country to young people ages 12 to 28 struggling with psychological and behavioral issues including depression, anxiety, and substance abuse. Learn more. at Newporthealthcare.com. So there's another area you've looked at, though, which is cognitive behavioral therapy and its effect on inflammation.
并为与心理健康问题和共病作斗争的青少年和年轻人提供可持续的康复治疗。Newport Healthcare 致力于为受心理健康问题困扰的年轻人提供无障碍且符合道德的护理。Newport 在全国各地为年龄在 12 至 28 岁之间、正在与抑郁症、焦虑症和药物滥用等心理及行为问题作斗争的年轻人提供全方位的持续护理。了解更多信息请访问 Newporthealthcare.com。不过，你还研究过另一个领域，那就是认知行为疗法及其对炎症的影响。
Can you tell us a little bit about that research? Yes. So I'm a clinical psychologist by training. And cognitive behavior therapy is, which I'm sure many of listeners would be familiar with, is a different, let's say a different strategy or different way in. for reducing the negative impact that these thoughts would have on our brain and our body. So one of the key ideas behind cognitive behavior therapy or CBT is cognitive restructuring. And in a nutshell, what that involves is, first of all, being mindful about the thoughts that we're
你能给我们讲讲那项研究吗？好的。我受过临床心理学专业的训练。正如我确信许多听众所熟悉的那样，认知行为疗法是一种不同的，可以说是不同的策略或不同的切入点，用于减少这些想法对我们的大脑和身体产生的负面影响。因此，认知行为疗法（CBT）背后的关键理念之一就是认知重构。简而言之，这涉及的第一件事是对我们正在产生的
having in the moment. And in the CBT lingo, those are called. negative automatic thoughts. So if I'm going along my merry way and I'm walking down the street and I think to myself, wow, I really messed up. My boss is going to hate me for this. He's never or she's never going to trust me on an important project again. So clearly that's a negative automatic thought. It popped up into our mind. And when those thoughts are very emotionally charged, Oftentimes, the thoughts are exaggerated in a negative direction more so than what the evidence actually would suggest is true. And so the process of cognitive restructuring in the CBT framework is to, first of all,
当下的想法保持正念。用 CBT 的行话来说，这些被称为消极自动思维。如果我高高兴兴地走在街上，心里想，哇，我真的搞砸了。我的老板会因此讨厌我。他或她再也不会在一个重要的项目上信任我了。这显然是一个消极的自动思维。它突然蹦进我们的脑海。当这些想法带有非常强烈的情绪时，通常这些想法会在消极的方向上被夸大，甚至超过了实际证据所表明的真实情况。因此，CBT 框架下的认知重构过程，首先是
identify that negative thought when it pops into our mind, which, by the way, some of us are really good at doing and others of us feel negative for a long period of time without necessarily recognizing the thought that is causing that negative emotion. So I don't want to gloss over the mindfulness part because actually identifying why you're upset sounds simple, but can sometimes be quite complicated. So first of all, identifying the negative thought, maybe putting it down on paper or putting it on a whiteboard or writing it down, and then what you do in cognitive restructuring is act as a scientist. First of all, of all, you look, you say that thought, okay, my boss is never going to trust me again.
当消极想法蹦进脑海时识别出它。顺便说一句，我们有些人在这方面非常擅长，而另一些人则会在很长一段时间里感到消极，却不一定能识别出导致这种负面情绪的想法。所以我不想一带而过地略过正念部分，因为实际上识别你为什么难过听起来很简单，但有时却相当复杂。所以首先要识别消极想法，也许把它写在纸上或写在白板上，然后你在认知重构中所做的是像科学家一样行事。首先，你看着，你说那个想法，好吧，我的老板再也不会信任我了。
Now what your task is, is first of all, to identify all of the evidence that you have that supports that thought. Now, you're laughing, right? Because you recognize that the more ridiculous the thought is, let's say ridiculous, right? The less evidence-based the thought is, obviously, the fewer things you're going to be able to put down to support that thought. Then what you do, So once you're done with that column, now what you have to do is identify all of the evidence that does not support the thought. You know, this has happened before. My boss, you know, has continued to trust me. I've done a great job.
现在你的任务是，首先，找出你拥有的所有支持这一想法的证据。现在，你在笑，对吧？因为你认识到，想法越荒谬，我们假设是荒谬的吧，对吧？这个想法越缺乏证据支持，显而易见，你能写出来支持这个想法的事情就越少。然后你做什么呢，一旦你完成了那一栏，现在你必须找出所有不支持这个想法的证据。你知道，这以前发生过。我的老板，你知道，一直信任我。我做得很好。
You know, I've had other successful projects. My boss likes me. You know, if he or she didn't like me, he or she wouldn't trust me on such important projects, etc., etc., etc. So inevitably what happens is you have this very short list of evidence that supports the negative thought, and you have a very long list of evidence that does not support the negative thought. And then there's the final step, as a scientist would do, which is that to evaluate, to look at that negative thought you had, to look at the evidence that supports it, to look at the evidence that does not support it, and then to rewrite that thought now based on the balance of the evidence.
你知道，我有过其他成功的项目。我的老板喜欢我。你知道，如果他或她不喜欢我，他或她就不会在这么重要的项目上信任我，等等，等等，等等。所以不可避免发生的情况是，你有一份支持消极想法的非常短的证据清单，还有一份不支持消极想法的非常长的证据清单。然后是最后一步，正如科学家会做的那样，那就是评估，审视你曾经拥有的那个消极想法，审视支持它的证据，审视不支持它的证据，然后根据证据的平衡来重新改写那个想法。
So if the original thought was my boss is never going to trust me again because I messed up, the rewritten thought would be much more balanced and much more evidence-based and sounds something like mistakes sometimes happen. You know, I'm doing my best. I'm a valued member of the team and in my boss, understands that, you know, I'm doing my best and, you know, that, you know, failing is part of success and blah, blah, blah. You know, maybe I didn't say that so eloquently, but I want to highlight, the blah, blah,
所以，如果最初的想法是“我老板再重构后就会说，错误有时会发生。你知道，我尽力了。我是团队中有价值的一员，我的老板理解这一点，你知道，我正在尽力，而且，你知道，失败是成功的一部分，等等等等。你知道，也许我说得没那么生动，但我想强调的是，那个‘等等等等’
blah part wasn't very eloquent. What I want to highlight is that that that rewritten thought should be the result of you processing really what the reality of the situation is. And then finally, you just need to work on owning those thoughts that are much more evidence-based. And, you know, it's like riding the bike. You know, when you first do this cognitive restructuring, it involves a lot of time and effort. You need to write your thoughts down and sort of separate yourself from them. You actually, you know, you can actually write the evidence that's for and the evidence that's
部分并不是很有说服力。我想强调的是，那个改写后的想法应该是你真正处理当前实际情况的结果。最后，你需要努力去接纳那些更有证据支持的想法。而且，你知道，这就像骑自行车。当你第一次进行这种认知重构时，它需要大量的时间和精力。你需要把你的想法写下来，并把自己和它们分离开来。实际上，你知道，你实际上可以把支持和反对
against the thought on paper so that you can own it. But once you get good at it, just like writing a bike, you sort of learn to do this automatically where you'll just be walking along and that thought will pop up and you'll catch yourself and you'll say, whoa, whoa, whoa, that's really out there. I know I'm feeling that in the moment, but let's take a step back and examine whether that thought is actually, you know, to what extent that thought is actually true. And so you'll gain the ability to basically do that cognitive restructuring in the moment while you're walking down the street. And then instead of that thought bothering you for five, 10 minutes, one day, two days, all of a sudden you get to the point
该想法的证据写在纸上，这样你就能真正接受它。但一旦你熟练了，就像骑自行车一样，你就会学会自动做到这一点，你会走着走着，那个想法突然冒出来，然后你会抓住自己，你会说，哇，哇，哇，这太离谱了。我知道我当下有这种感觉，但让我们退一步，检查一下这个想法是否真的，你知道，这个想法在多大程度上是真的。于是你将获得这种能力，基本上能够在走在街上的当下进行这种认知重构。然后，这个想法不会再困扰你五分钟、十分钟、一天、两天，而是突然间你达到了这样一个境界：
where you quote unquote rewrite that thought so quickly that you only are in that negative emotional state for two minutes rather than two hours or two days. You really retrained yourself how to face it and get past it. That's good advice. So let me move to another area of research where you've done a lot of work, which is around the measurement of stress. You've developed something called the stress and adversity inventory, which aims to quantify people's lifetime exposure to stress. Can you talk about why it's important to be able to quantify and measure stress and how the inventory works? Absolutely. So in any other area of medicine, you would never, for example, in surgery, you would never cut somebody open or you may never convince somebody to be cut open.
你所谓的重写那个想法的速度如此之快，以至于你处于负面情绪状态的时间只有两分钟，而不是两小时或两天。你真正重新训练了自己如何面对并跨过去。这是个好建议。那么，让我转向你做过大量工作的另一个研究领域，即关于压力的测量。你开发了一种名为“压力与逆境量表”的工具，旨在量化人们一生中对压力的接触。你能谈谈为什么能够量化和测量压力如此重要，以及这个量表是如何运作的吗？当然。在医学的任何其他领域，你绝对不会，例如在外科手术中，你绝对不会把人切开，或者你可能永远不会说服别人接受手术，
if you didn't give them some reason for why the surgery was necessary. You also have to make decisions about how much you should really care about the treatment or how high on the priority list of particular treatment should be. Or for interventions that are invasive, whether, you know, what the cost-benefit is to intervening quickly and now, versus waiting a while. I use this analogy because I think that in other areas of medicine, you would never get people to engage in a particular treatment
如果你没有给他们提供某种理由来解释为什么手术是必要的。你还得做出决定，关于你究竟应该多么关心这种治疗，或者某种特定治疗在优先级列表中应该排在多高。或者对于侵入性干预措施而言，权衡现在迅速干预与等待一段时间之间的成本效益如何。我用这个类比是因为我认为在医学的其他领域，你绝对无法让人参与某种治疗
or even to understand how important the treatment is if you didn't give them a hard metric about how well or how poorly they were doing. So in the case of a cancerous tumor, for example, if you image that tumor and you sit down with a patient and you put an x-ray or some other imaging of that tumor up on the board and you say, you know, you've been feeling really crappy for the past six months. The reason for that, unfortunately, is that you have this cancerous tumor inside of you. Now, I want to let you know that we have this therapeutic technique that is going to be able to take care of that, but it's going to require a lot of motivation
甚至无法让人理解这种治疗有多重要，除非你给他们一个硬性指标，说明他们做得有多好或有多差。因此，以癌症肿瘤为例，如果你对该肿瘤进行影像学检查，并与患者坐在一起，将该肿瘤的X光片或其他影像放到黑板上，然后你说，你知道的，你过去六个月感觉糟透了。不幸的是，原因在于你体内长了这个癌症肿瘤。现在，我想让你知道，我们拥有这种治疗技术，能够处理掉它，但这需要大量的动机
on your part. It's going to require adhering to a treatment that is not going to be, you know, that is going to require a lot of effort, but it has a high success rate. So if you stick with me and stick with this treatment for six months, we're going to get through this together and you're going to feel much better. Now all of a sudden, when you have that metric, you fully understand what the hell is going on and why you should garner up the motivation to get on the treatment plan and to really see this through. And actually, you know, reducing your stress and moving toward wellness in life, you know, not trying to make the analogy that being really stressed out is better or worse than having cancer, but you can also die from stress. And for, for
由你来承担。它需要坚持一种并不轻松的、需要付出巨大努力的治疗方案，但它的成功率很高。所以，如果你坚持配合我，坚持这个治疗方案六个月，我们就能一起挺过去，你会感觉好多了。现在突然间，当你有了这个指标，你完全明白了到底是怎么回事，以及为什么要振作起动力加入治疗计划并真正坚持到底。实际上，你知道，减轻你的压力并走向生活中的健康，你知道，并不是想做这样的类比：压力山大比患癌症更好或更糟，但你也会死于压力。并且，对于
some of us, stress can really be quite impactful. And stress can also come from a lot of sources, being in a terrible relationship, having the nasty boss, having a job that is not bringing us joy, taking on too many responsibilities at work, having difficult financial situations. And what I want to say is that in order to be motivated to really realign our life with our purpose, if you like the idea of Dharma, to identify whether or not we're really pursuing our Dharma, whether or not we are living the life to the fullest in the way that we really, that is meaningful and that brings us joy and purpose, requires a lot of motivation. motivation and time and effort.
我们中的一些人来说，压力确实会产生相当大的影响。压力也可能来自很多来源，处于糟糕的关系中，遇到讨厌的老板，有一份不能给我们带来快乐的工作，在工作中承担了太多责任，面对困难的财务状况。我想说的是，为了有动力真正让我们的生活与我们的目标重新对齐，如果你喜欢“达摩”（Dharma）的概念，去识别我们是否真的在追求我们的达摩，我们是否在以真正有意义、给我们带来快乐和目标的方式充实地生活，这需要大量的动机、时间和精力。
And so long, it's my monologue again, I apologize. But what I want to say is that the reason you need to assess stress clearly and with a clear metric is that, first of all, you need to build motivation for making difficult changes in life. That's the point. And if you don't assess it, then you can't address it. It's very difficult to get somebody on board with making difficult changes in their life or adhering to a challenging treatment regimen if you don't know what the magnitude of the
所以说了很久，这又是我的长篇大论，我道歉。但我想说的是，你需要清晰地评估压力并拥有一个明确指标的原因是，首先，你需要在生活中做出艰难改变时建立动力。这就是重点。如果你不评估它，你就无法解决它。如果你不知道问题的严重性，就很难让某人参与到他们生活中艰难改变的做出中，或者坚持一个具有挑战性的治疗方案。
problem is. And so, for example, if I say that I'm stressed out, I'm really stressed out. Well, what does that mean? I'm on a scale from 1 to 10? Does that mean I'm a 3 out of 10 or does that mean I'm a 9 out of 10? And if a nine out of 10 means that my risk for having a cardiac event, a heart attack, you know, in the next five years, is now 85%, well, all of a sudden, that's going to, it's going to motivate me quite strongly to look at my stress levels in an objective way
因此，举个例子，如果我说我压力很大，我真的压力很大。好吧，那意味着什么？在一到十的量表上？这意味我是10分里的3分，还是10分里的9分？如果9分意味着我在未来五年内心脏事件、心脏病发作的风险现在达到了85%，好吧，突然之间，这将非常强烈地激励我以客观的方式审视我的压力水平。
as compared to somebody else, understand, you know, whether or not my stress is higher than normal, less, you know, lower than normal, and also, you know, in which areas of my life I can make positive changes. And that's really what the stress and adversity inventory is all about, the strain, which is about creating concrete metrics, population level metrics, to understand how much stress have you actually experienced as compared to other people of similar gender and age, et cetera, so that when you're feeling really stressed out, you can estimate in a concrete way your actual health risks that are associated with stress. And so the inventory involves looking at the stressors that you have experienced across
与其他人相比，你知道的，了解我的压力是否高于正常水平、较少，你知道的，低于正常水平，以及，你知道的，在我生活的哪些方面我可以做出积极的改变。这正是压力与逆境调查表（Stress and Adversity Inventory）的意义所在，即通过建立具体的指标、群体层面的指标，来了解与同性别和年龄等其他类似的人相比，你实际经历了多少压力，以便当你感到压力山大时，你可以用具体的方式估计与压力相关的实际健康风险。因此，该调查包括审视你所经历的各种压力源
your whole lifespan. I mean, is that what you're trying to do and then give people a number to say that, you know, you're an eight and you're going to have a heart attack in five years, like you said, unless you'd make a change in your life? Yeah, that's right. The lifetime part is really important because if you go online and you take these stress measures, and by the way, there are a bazillion of them online, the amount of time period that's covered by those questions is really important. So, for example, some of them only focus on things that happen to you before age 18.
你的整个人生历程。我的意思是，这正是你们想要做的，然后给人们一个数字，说明，你知道的，你处于8级，五年内你会得心脏病，就像你说的，除非你在生活中做出改变？是的，没错。生命周期的部分真的很重要，因为如果你上网参加这些压力评估，顺便说一句，网上有成千上万个这样的评估，这些问题所涵盖的时间段真的很重要。例如，其中一些只关注你在18岁之前发生的事情。
And we know that early life stress is really important. It's when the brain and the body are developing. And so if you've experienced a lot of early life stress, your brain and body, you know, developed to be, for example, more threat sensitive maybe than somebody who hasn't experienced those stressors. But, you know, I'm here to tell you that stress doesn't end when you turn 18. So if you're only assessing stress early in life, you may be missing out on 10, 20, 30, 50 years of stress exposure.
我们知道早年生活压力非常重要。那是大脑和身体发育的时期。因此，如果你经历了很多早年生活压力，你的大脑和身体，你知道的，发育得可能比没有经历过这些压力的人对威胁更敏感。但是，你知道的，我在这里告诉你，当你满18岁时，压力并不会结束。因此，如果你只评估生命早期的压力，你可能会漏掉10年、20年、30年、50年的压力暴露。
Other instruments online ask you about things that you might have experienced over the past week. And those things that experienced over the past week may be really relevant for how anxious or sad or disconnected you feel right now. But a lot of the biology that underpins chronic disease is much more prolonged and persistent and slowly developing. So only assessing stressors that occur over the past week may not be sufficient for really coming to an estimate of chronic disease risk simply because it's the chronic stressors that are around in our lives for much longer than a week that really engage the immune system, upregulate inflammation, cause oxidative stress, lead to the development of cancer tumors and biological aging and
网上的其他工具会询问你在过去一周内可能经历的事情。你在过去一周经历的事情可能与你现在感到多么焦虑、悲伤或脱节高度相关。但是，构成慢性病基础的许多生物学特性更加长期、持续且缓慢发展。因此，仅评估过去一周发生的压力源可能不足以真正得出慢性病风险的估计，因为正是那些在我们生活中存在远超一周的慢性压力源，才真正激活了免疫系统、上调了炎症、导致了氧化应激、促成了肿瘤的生长和生物学衰老，以及
etc. So you really need a panoramic snapshot, I think, of all of the things you've experienced over your entire life course, and that's what an instrument like the stress and adversity inventory affords us. So I want to talk for a minute about some other research that you've done that it still shows a connection between stress and health, and that's a study that you did on how acetaminophen, which most of us know as Tylenol, might affect people who have experienced social rejection. Can you talk about those findings because I think they're fascinating? Thanks for bringing that up.
等等。因此，我认为，你确实需要一个全景式的快照，了解你一生中经历的所有事情，而这正是像压力与逆境调查表这样的工具带给我们的。所以我接下来想花一点时间谈谈你做过的一些其他研究，这些研究仍然显示了压力与健康之间的联系，那是关于对乙酰氨基酚（我们大多数人将其称为泰诺）如何影响经历过社会排斥的人的一项研究。你能谈谈这些发现吗，因为我认为它们太迷人了？谢谢你提出这个话题。
So we ran a clinical trial a few years ago where we essentially followed individuals over time. And we randomly assigned the participants in this study to take acetaminopin for several weeks in one group or to not take to basically take a placebo pill in the other group. So if you're a participant in this study, you either. assigned to take acetametaphine for several weeks, or you take a pill that you don't know. Well, nobody in the group obviously knows what they're taking. So you're either taking the placebo pill or the acetamapamine. And then what we did was we followed folks over time, and we assessed their levels of social pain on each of these weeks.
因此，我们在几年前进行了一项临床试验，我们基本上在一段时间内追踪了个人。我们随机分配本研究的参与者在一个组中连续几周服用对乙酰氨基酚，或者在另一组中不服用，基本上是服用安慰剂药丸。因此，如果你是本研究的参与者，你要么被分配连续几周服用对乙酰氨基酚，要么服用一种你不知道的药丸。当然，小组中的任何人都不知道自己吃的是什么。所以你要么服用安慰剂药丸，要么服用对乙酰氨基酚。然后我们做的是，我们在一段时间内追踪这些人，并评估他们在每周的社会痛苦水平。
And we just asked the question, you know, can acetymedophon reduce your experiences of social pain over time as compared to taking this placebo pill that doesn't have that active ingredient? And the neurobiology behind this is quite interesting. If you put individuals in an fMRI brain scanner and you expose them to some kind of physical pain, so you're lying in the fMRI scanner on your back, you're in this huge magnet, and now on your leg, I put a heat pad that's going to cause some acute, you know, acute physical pain. That physical pain isn't going to engage, of course, centers in your brain that are involved in representing physical pain. Stick with me here.
我们只是提出了这样一个问题，你知道的，与服用没有这种活性成分的安慰剂药丸相比，对乙酰氨基酚能否随着时间的推移减少你对社会痛苦的体验？这背后的神经生物学非常有趣。如果你把个人放进fMRI（功能性磁共振成像）大脑扫描仪中，让他们暴露于某种身体痛苦中，也就是你躺在fMRI扫描仪中仰卧，你在这个巨大的磁铁里，现在我在你的腿上放一个加热垫，这会引起一些急性的，你知道的，急性的身体痛苦。这种身体痛苦当然会激活大脑中代表身体痛苦的中枢。请听我继续说。
But now if I put you in that same fMRI scanner and I introduce you to two other individuals who you re they seemingly nice individuals. But now while you're in the fMRI scanner, I have you play a game where all of a sudden those two individuals start excluding you or rejecting you. Okay, so that's not a physical stressor. It's a purely social stressor. What we found is that some of the same neural circuitry that gets activated or engaged when you're exposed to physical pain,
但是，如果我现在把你放进同一个fMRI扫描仪中，并把你介绍给另外两个人，他们看起来是很好的人。但现在当你在fMRI扫描仪中时，我让你玩一个游戏，突然那两个人开始排斥你或拒绝你。好吧，这不是一个身体压力源。这纯粹是一个社会压力源。我们发现，当你暴露于身体痛苦时被激活或参与的一些相同的神经回路，
the heat pad, is some of the same neural circuitry that gets activated or engaged when you're exposed to social exclusion or rejection. which is quite fascinating. So you think of, you know, like when you're rejected, you, you know, you have all these physical terms. You know, my heart is broken. And we think one explanation for that may be that there's some, to some extent, some neurobiological overlap of the way in which the brain and the body processes physical pain and social pain. So this comes back to the study that you mentioned, right? Why would we even think in our wildest, dreams that if somebody was experiencing physical pain, that you would give them a
加热垫，也是当你暴露于社会排斥或拒绝时被激活或参与的相同神经回路的一部分。这非常迷人。所以你会想到，你知道的，就像当你被拒绝时，你，你知道的，你会使用所有这些身体方面的词汇。你知道，我的心碎了。我们认为对此的一种解释可能是，在某种程度上，大脑和身体处理身体痛苦和社会痛苦的方式存在某种神经生物学上的重叠。所以这回到了你提到的那项研究，对吧？为什么我们会在异想天开的梦想中认为，如果有人正在经历身体痛苦，你会给他们
acetametamine because that just sounds totally crazy, right? You take a Cetamethin when you're experiencing physical pain, not when you're socially rejected. So that's the whole logic behind, that's the neurobiological explanation for why we thought that a Cidometophon might help individuals get through a socially painful experience. and come out more resilient than individuals who went about their lives and experienced social pain on a day-to-day basis, but were not taking cedometifen. Long story short, what we think a cedomepin might be doing in this study is turning down the volume on the physical slash social pain signal.
对乙酰氨基酚，因为这听起来太疯狂了，对吧？当你经历身体痛苦时，你会服用对乙酰氨基酚，而不是在你受到社会排斥时。所以这背后的整个逻辑，就是为什么我们认为对乙酰氨基酚可能有助于个人度过社交痛苦经历的神经生物学解释，并比那些在日常生活中经历社会痛苦但没有服用对乙酰氨基酚的人表现得更有复原力。长话短说，我们认为对乙酰氨基酚在这项研究中可能在做的事情是调低身体/社会痛苦信号的音量。
So if you're a type of individual who goes about their lives and you feel really sensitive, to disagreements or to social conflict. Or let's say you have that sort of nasty boss conversation coming up and you know that you're going to experience some social pain, experience it being socially rejected or socially evaluated. What the study suggests is that you may be able to tune down the volume on that negative social pain frequency by taking some acetametaphine prior and leading up to that meeting.
因此，如果你是一个在生活中习惯于对分歧或社会冲突感到非常敏感的人。或者假设你即将与那位讨厌的老板进行那场谈话，并且你知道你会经历一些社会痛苦，经历被社会拒绝或社会评估。该研究表明，你或许能够通过在会面前及期间服用一些对乙酰氨基酚，来调低那种负面社会痛苦频率的音量。
Now, the big caveat is that this was not a big study. And like any great scientist, what I think we need to do is replicate that work using obviously more participants, more diverse samples. And also to really understand what it is that acetaminopin is doing in the brain and the body so that we understand the mechanisms of action and can approach this in the most scientifically sound way possible. But the reason I like this study is that we know that common treatments for depression and anxiety disorders can be effective, but they're not as effective for as many people as we need them to be. So in the context of depression, for example, SSRIs are only effective for about 40 to 60%
现在，最大的注意事项是，这不是一项大型研究。像任何伟大的科学家一样，我认为我们需要做的是利用更多的参与者、更多样化的样本来复制这项工作。并且还要真正了解对乙酰氨基酚在大脑和身体中到底在做什么，以便我们了解其作用机制，并以最科学合理的方式处理这个问题。但我喜欢这项研究的原因在于，我们知道治疗抑郁症和焦虑症的常见疗法可能是有效的，但它们对我们需要它们发挥作用的那么多人来说并不是那么有效。因此，以抑郁症为例，SSRIs（选择性5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂）仅对大约40%到60%的人有效
of individuals who take them. And of course, 40 to 50% is better than 5% to 10%, but we need to get to a point where we have therapeutics that are successful, you know, for 80 to 10%. 90%. Another way of saying it is that I think we need more therapeutics in our toolbox to help folks who are experiencing stress, anxiety, and depression during these difficult times. So our goal in this study is just to say, you know, we're not sure now whether acetametaphane or similar therapeutics might be something that we could recommend for dropping into the toolbox, but we know that we need to keep our eyes wide open for any kind of tools beyond the ones that
服用它们的人。当然，40%到50%总比5%到10%要好，但我们需要达到这样一个地步，即我们的疗法能够成功，你知道的，对80%到90%的人有效。换句话说，我认为我们的工具箱中需要更多疗法，来帮助那些在这些困难时期经历压力、焦虑和抑郁的人们。因此，我们在这项研究中的目标只是说，你知道的，我们现在还不确定对乙酰氨基酚或类似的疗法是否是我们可能会建议放入工具箱的东西，但我们知道我们需要睁大眼睛，寻找超出我们目前拥有的任何工具之外的工具
we currently have and say, you know, anything that works, we're willing to consider. Let's test it out and see how good it does. Well, Dr. Slavich, this has been really interesting. I think you've given us some things to think about. There are some treatments out there that are simple, mindfulness, meditation, cognitive behavioral therapy, ways that you've already shown we can alleviate some of the stress in our lives. So I want to thank you for being with us today. Thank you. And I would just like to end by saying, I think this, we are all in this snow globe that's being shook up for two years. And it's very easy to focus on the negative side of that. But what I want to leave us all with is the question of where we will land in that landscape. If we're floating
我们目前拥有的，并说，你知道的，任何管用的方法，我们都愿意考虑。让我们测试一下，看看它效果有多好。好吧，斯拉维奇博士，这真的非常有趣。我认为你给我们提供了一些值得思考的事情。有一些治疗方法很简单，比如正念、冥想、认知行为疗法，这些都是你已经证明我们可以用来减轻生活中部分压力的方法. 所以我要感谢你今天来到我们的节目中。谢谢你。我只想最后说一句，我认为我们所有人都处于一个被摇晃了两年之久的雪球之中。人们很容易只看到消极的一面。但我想留给大家的问题是，我们将落脚于那个风景中的哪个地方。如果我们正漂浮着
around in that snow globe right now, let's look at that as an opportunity maybe for landing on the ground in a place that feels better, more comfortable. more socially connected and more resilient than wherever it was we were on that landscape before this situation all started. So that's my hope for myself and for you and for all of our listeners out there. Let's use this snow globe situation to land in a better, more resilient, more peaceful, more compassionate world. Thank you. You're absolutely right. I couldn't agree more. You can find more information on APA's Stress in America survey and more resources on managing stress on APA's website at APA.org. And you can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts.
现在就在那个雪球里，让我们把这看作是一个机会，也许可以降落在地面上一个感觉更好、更舒适、社会联系更多、比在这场危机开始之前我们在那个风景中的任何地方都更有复原力的舒适地方。这就是我对我自己、对你以及对所有听众的期望。让我们利用这个雪球般的情况，降落在一个更好、更有复原力、更和平、更有同情心的世界里。谢谢你。你说得完全对。我完全赞同。你可以在美国心理协会（APA）的网站 APA.org 上找到关于 APA 美国压力调查的更多信息以及更多关于管理压力的资源。你还可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Stitcher 以及你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology）以前的节目。
And if you listen on Apple, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你在 Apple 上收听，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以通过电子邮件将意见发送至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学对话》由莉·韦内尔曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·康迪汉（Chris Condihan）。感谢收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理协会。该期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。